so Trump and Bernie Sanders ran the same
type of campaign simultaneously and
because they were both seeing the
symptoms of this sugar high money cycle
of fewer and fewer people getting really
rich Bernie came at it from an outright
Marxist view Trump came at it from a
populist nationalist View and Bernie
Sanders should have really been the
nominee in 2016 but Hillary Clinton
rigged the game Trump became the nominee
and obviously won in a shocking fashion
what we are now living through 14 years
later is the economic catastrophe of
Timothy Geithner and Ben Bernanke and
Hank Paulson but here's the thing and
this is why James Lindsay's work is so
incredible these corporations think they
are immune to criticism and Revolution
because they have wokeness as a shield
they have an Iron Dome they think they
are protected from criticism because
they can say men can become pregnant
white people are evil wokism is the only
thing they have left protecting them
from hundreds of millions of people
realizing that they're robber barons
against the civilization the first time
I encountered the witness
whatever Occupy Wall Street
initially you know I'm down there and
I'm sure Luke has similar experiences
there's a lot of people who are just
economic populists they say I don't know
the two parties are bad whatever but
then all of a sudden these these
organizers started gaining more and more
traction who believed in the Progressive
stack and white men are evil there's a
good comic that embodies this and it's a
rich guy in a big chair with protesters
outside saying we are the 99 and he's on
the phone saying introduce them to
Identity politics all of a sudden
wokeness started taking over and then
from there I started I started seeing it
get bigger and bigger and you know what
for me I didn't think much of it other
than these people are weirdos despite
the fact that I remember one night there
was there was a a young black guy who
was watching all of this happen and I
overheard him say y'all are crazy you're
segregating people by race one of them I
don't have anything to do with this
occupy actually created their
organizational structure based around
your race they put all the black people
in one group all the Latinos all the
Asians yeah it was and and I wonder why
it fell apart no wonder right yeah and
then over a period of time time there
was the upper class and the lower class
divided by two different areas of the
park where they were fighting and
segregated other body parts and I truly
do believe I truly do believe that there
was a larger hijacking of this movement
because when it began there was people
doing weekly even sometimes in the
beginning daily walks and protests at
the Federal Reserve down in New York
City down on Wall Street they came down
there and they were like hey guys this
is not just about uh left or right this
is about the big Banks the banks that
are screwing us over the banks that are
robbing us of our wealth robbing us of
any potential future this is the
creature from Jekyll Island that came in
and is dominating and destroying our
society because what else could you say
that they did during 2008 other than a
blind robbery of the American people I
went up to Ben Bernanke and I asked them
how does it feel organizing one of the
largest bailouts in recorded human
history for all your Banker buddies
giving them trillions of dollars the SOB
tried to grab my microphone and rip it
away from me and he didn't say a word
then I asked him about the Bilderberg
Group he didn't want to talk about that
either no surprise there but but these
people are are criminals these people
are essentially people don't notice this
inflation is one of the biggest taxes
levied on the American people we are
going through essentially what is your
wealth being taken away from you every
single day by these banksters and unless
you're focusing on the big Banks you're
not focusing on the big problems it's
one big picture
I didn't mean to say hurry up I was
saying no no like it's no no no ESG I
mean this is right reset this connects
yeah this is everything if you this is
what you got to understand ESG is is a
tool so they can protect the banks by
creating a social credit system for the
corporations they all do the same thing
organized by the top Bankers that's
right that's right and what they learned
when Charlie brought up wokeness a
minute ago and gave me a very kind
compliment what he what you also don't
realize is the reason I do what I do is
because of the progressive stack as it
turns out it's a little bit funny I'll
tell you in a second biggest audience
I've ever had a chance to tell this
story to I get asked about it all the
time but what they learned in 2008 is
that wokeness works wokeness gives them
a sword and a shield at the same time
that they can wield that and protect
themselves they can go out and break up
a movement like occupy by bringing
identity politics and wokeness into it
and meanwhile look like the super
virtuous people who care about gay
people and have a rainbow on their on
their Shield this is what they learned
but it turns out by the way you brought
the progressive stack why am I studying
wokeness why did I dedicate my life to
studying this crap so I'm writing this
fake paper back in 2017 about education
I've told this story a few times how I
got there is another story
and I'm writing this paper and we we say
what we need to do is put a progressive
stack in all the classrooms what we got
to do is we got to take all the kids and
the the college students if they're
adults and if they have we're going to
do the progressive stack walk or the
privilege Walk we're going to find out
the Privileges we're gonna we're gonna
chain them to the floor if they have too
much privilege we're going to make sure
that they suffer that they're abused
that they're put into the learning
environment of discomfort to overcome
their privilege and then we said but
we're going to do it compassionately
because we're writing funny hoax papers
that they didn't think they would accept
and the peer reviewers reviewed this
paper this is how gone Academia is they
reviewed this paper and said we love
this idea but you can't use compassion
because that would re-center the needs
of the privileged you have to focus on
more discomfort the pedagogy of
discomfort from this woman Megan Buller
which we hadn't heard of at the time so
we get this book and read it it's called
feeling power it's insane and I was like
holy crap this is where I mean this is
this is a this isn't just crazy this is
a genocide in the making down the road
if you are saying that you're going to
abuse people out of their privilege
score them by their abuse them out of
their privilege and you must use
discomfort and no compassion once you've
been identified as privilege this is a
danger so I said maybe I was wrong about
that I'm not claiming that's what it is
don't don't that was my thought and I
thought I have to study this for the
rest of my life and expose this and what
Charlie said is why because wokeness is
The Sword and the shield that they have
that allows them to protect it's the
last thing they have that allows them to
keep this criminal front girl going I
want to break up one point to what
Charlie said because I'm very happy you
brought up Occupy Wall Street because uh
Occupy Wall Street I do believe scared
the establishment I do believe the
movement was hijacked but that's one
thing that changed another thing that
changed was the way that the corporate
media had their conversations and we saw
a very big rise with organizations like
the New York Times start implementing a
lot of their woke policies right after
Occupy Wall Street because what better
way to divide and conquer a population
that of course have them in fighting
against each other so they don't truly
see the true source of their problems
and that's exactly what happened they
want Americans fighting each other
that's right they want you hating each
other they want you divided they want
you angry they want you pissed off and
the best way to not engage is to not
play along with their bullcrap so the
challenge is for us were anti-woke you
know we say hey don't divide People
based on race or these these immutable
characters let's let people be who their
character their Merit Etc
but now the battle is that that's the
division Luke it's the people who want
to divide versus the people who don't
want to divide creating this weird
division
and they brand themselves as Unity
wouldn't that wouldn't that would they
just be perfect right well so my
question for you James I guess is if
this is their sword and their Shield
does it end by just collapsing in front
of them or does it what does it become
is there a way that the establishment
successfully wields this to their
advantage in the end well I mean I think
wokeness is actually now turning to
their disadvantage people are seeing it
has been exposed people are getting
upset I told uh some of my friends and
colleagues back in 2019 that if they
ever went full into the queer Theory so
unleash the drag queens that they had
shot themselves in the head it's only a
matter of time until thing Falls over
people aren't going to put up with that
for very long they're gonna and it
doesn't mean that you have to go do
something in in in you know something
crazy it's not what I mean by saying
that people aren't going to put up with
it they're going to see through that
this is fake this is fake so then what
happens we start to have these media
Awards they start Banning people off
everything that they're doing is
actually just kind of this accumulation
of weight that's causing that thing to
fall down so they have this sword in the
shield but it's getting dull The Shield
is getting soft and eventually we're
going to hit a critical mass and that's
how it always works that's why Steve's
always pointing to you and saying that
you're the solution that you're the
answer that you are uh what's your word
for it Steve the the you always call him
the the
I thought praetorian guard that's wrong
oh the force multiplier the force
multiplier yeah yeah no it's look the
big their biggest fear right now is that
you come to conferences like this you
get smarter and not just that it's
applied knowledge the reason they're
trying to take out everybody and
de-platform everybody and stop it all
and take you know go after Tucker and go
after everybody is because they fear you
that's right they understand they
haven't had a true populist Uprising in
this country in its history right not a
true populist Uprising the only way to
defeat it is a populist Uprising and
that is you so one of the ways I think
that it's going to
be exploited
is
economic marxists on the left
when they start to realize the people
they were indoctrinated to hate are
actually running the political party
that they're affiliated with when that
is exploited all of a sudden there will
be a massive Schism on the American left
wokism and people that are legitimate
Bolsheviks that believe in the economics
of Marxism but are not as enthused on
the race Marxist stuff that is going to
be a Schism because the vast majority of
Americans see that it's harder than ever
to buy a home that Consumer Debt is
increasing that your money is becoming
worthless those messages are going to
resonate like wildfire in the coming
months the coming years especially as
now I think we're going to hit a mass
unemployment cycle what's less and less
popular is hearing about privilege walks
or hearing about pan-trans awareness day
or drag queen Story Hour again wokism is
a smoke screen grenade it is trying to
confuse you it's a shock bang grenade to
try to say I don't know what direction
things are as soon as the the economics
of this will hit everybody's pocket put
in the upcoming months that's why
they're so afraid they're afraid that
the woke ideas are becoming largely
unpopular and that the economic reality
that's about to set in is going to unite
almost everybody on the right on the
left to point at the uniparty and say
you've been stealing from us for the
last couple decades and I'm not okay
with that and disenfranchising us from
our own country yes disenfranchising us
from our own country that's so important
to understand that we're being
disenfranchised from our own country
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time